I blundered a piece it happens but no
Bishop C7 would be great except for the
oh no way
oh my gosh
oh Nakamura is surviving
oh
he buttered The Rock oh my gosh oh you
can't stop me oh my God
he had the Intermezzo and he missed it
and now it's drunk where's the mate
though I don't know but it's gotta be
there oh my God
oh oh my gosh
[Music]
or Rook D2 wins a piece oh my goodness
rookie one move it goes behind the okay
A5
oh he's gone he played it with point one
seconds oh my gosh he's getting Queen
but Knight takes Knight takes a two oh
my God it's C2 Dimitri on Jake Drake is
a wizard he wins again and now he
doesn't even have to mate with Knight
and Bishop because he's gonna win all
his pawns he's Checkmate it's mate oh my
God Dimitri on draken is Unstoppable no
but now Bishop G4 and Rook F2 and black
should be winning
oh
Dimitri is beside himself oh my God he
plundered and now he's up with a million
bonds
and but Robert Lavon down to two seconds
yeah look at that clock that is
Dimitri's Only Hope right now is that he
Flags oh my gosh and Dimitri barely gave
the moves off in time move to G2 where
is he going just run away oh it's almost
me F6 is almost made
the pawn stopped oh but he gives a B5 no
Rook B7 would be seven that's you an H7
and Robert Bishop H5 at the end just go
H7
good point but then F5 he's got a flag
hey who's that time oh he lost the time
he's beside himself he's so upset and
that's the match Livonia right God drink
of whatever he's been drinking but it's
led him to success in the bud he gives
away a little bit of a smile there
G7 white who's winning White's winning
it's made for white where's the mate
though I don't know but it's gotta be
there oh my God
oh my gosh oh
oh no and suddenly and yeah in that
scenario it would be close uh oh and key
six beautiful technique and King D5
diagonal opposition shouldering and a
win
takes it work out three takes in Rook
half three oh Mike if he finds that I'm
I'm I'm walking away he's got the time
goodness sake he's got the moves oh my
God wow this is unbelievable and he wins
the second piece
dude anisha's form is killer right now
that is so sharp how did he find out
that with only 10 seconds
this move allows him nice he said oh my
God and there's H4 made at the end oh my
God
[Music]
rookie seven it's mate there's gonna be
H4 checkmate
what a mate don't blunder with Queen C1
easy to blunder your queen here
five Queen A1 though
this also wins this also wins oh God
no he's got a flag oh my God oh my God
oh my God he's gonna what no he flagged
and flagged he flagged oh he flagged oh
jingly run flat and you play King G1
king of two King E2 King D2 King C2 King
B2 and then just play G for it and
attack
that's like the petrosion idea I love it
I think you should try it there's
literally nothing to lose get your king
to the queen side and go G4 oh my gosh
or just at least put the king like he's
doing it oh he's doing it I think he's
going King F1 he's just double checking
to make sure that he doesn't cross any
danger zones oh
this is such a satisfying moment for you
oh my God oh my gosh black might have
had Knight D4 check there in the middle
but anyway I
I was like a bit worried there was
always a B5 or some sacrifice oh my gosh
she's actually gonna walk his King and
maybe play G4 he's doing it and he's not
afraid of Wesley playing B5 because
Wesley cannot divert a single piece from
their defense of the E5 fund that's why
it's so bad to have a weakness like this
and there this is my is my this is my is
my most accomplished moment as a chess
comedy from step five there's F3 and G4
and it's all three of G4 Bishop G5 it
has to give up the exchange and so oh my
God and he might still get mated on e4
okay you have Rook D1 oh
that was sick oh my God that was nasty
oh what a mate that he weaved how often
does a king get checkmated in the middle
of the board on F4
the bishop end game was winning now the
pawn moves forward to E5 really scared
Rook B7 rugby oh he buttered The Rook oh
my gosh he blunders a rook out of E1 it
resigns and nihal sarin is right back in
this match and Karo cannot believe it G6
Gucci
it's still a draw Queen C4 Hikaru
getting more and more frustrated
did he get the sun dial Queen F7 is King
running to f8 oh my God oh my God
th8
he whips the game F5 ba Queen there's no
checks there's not a single check
the least likely Square on the
chessboard and that's where he went oh
my gosh and now he doesn't even need to
trade Queens he could have but he's
gonna win these pawns and oh wait but
there's still a bunch of checks here oh
my gosh it's still not over
no this is yeah he's got everything he
wants he's connected G5 hangs oh what
defensive Brazilians by knee Hall but
it's not quite enough and Hikaru steals
it in exactly a hundred moves watch out
for H for H5 as well so black spawns
pushing white pushing on the fight Rook
84. what a move attacking the bishop
attacking the Knight now Knight takes F4
gets checkmated and rookie for hg6 how
is it surviving oh my God
what a move no no Rook H5 Queen D4 Queen
F2 oh my gosh one he goes we are winning
it's over holy sh oh my God cheese balls
look at those pawns on the sixth record
six Space Invaders up there and if going
down holy smokes and he car we're gonna
milk off as much time as he can Hikaru
is a grizzled veteran of the SEC format
he knows that there's not gonna be a
quick draw and nihal great with the
mouse speed he's just gonna move quickly
oh
my gosh
oh he skewed him
there are no words so interesting so
full of detail and hikara with yet
another incredible defensive effort
Robert
and look at a car he's surprised by Max
whoa whoa whoa five and look he's got a
mouse
I don't think so
gotta be a mouth it's like a souped up
Budapest Gambit with a bishop already
feeling kettled also car's like I'm the
one who plays these lines look at
magnus's clock he is again down two
minutes and the position is just getting
more and more out of hand
it is he's just a loud
Knight F4 and it's mate yeah hey car
season he's a car can't believe it he
looked at this
this is basic Brian Robert this is an
idea that occurs across all openings
this is universal and you can't step
back to the first rank because if Rook
C1 with mate it's over yeah I know
Hikaru saw it and look at him he's like
are you serious am I really playing
Magic this is all you got he says to
Magnus he's gonna be up four points and
Magnus has got a match on his hands
doesn't he oh a match I mean he's gonna
have to work hard to stay Queen H3
look at that me
yeah
run over 457. you might just win a pot
not quite yet though the Knight
defending that square but the moment it
moves you are leaning into C7 all right
I got you I got you I got you all right
that's on the piece there yeah but you
know it's my rules of commentary you
always have to be willing to be
incorrect I blundered a piece it happens
but no Bishop C7 would be great except
for the oh no wait
oh my gosh
are you kidding me I think I should
apologize to that am I true is this a
dream
if it is a car never wants to wake up
it's not already more seconds
he's lost his position does he have
enough time oh my gosh Magnus has to
show off the mouse speed right now
because this is a winning position for
white he is winning a second Pawn just
like a car did in a previous game
Magnus cannot afford to waste a single
second this could be over if Hikaru can
bleed another minute off the batch clock
here we go one minute 10 seconds every
second counts he checks he's gonna win
G5
and King G7 seven it's winning oh my God
no but Hikaru he has 15 more seconds he
needs to bleed 15 seconds
if you're Magnus your car is gonna make
it happen
Magnus gives a little bit clap for
Hikaru Nakamura but what a performance
from the American Superstar he has won
the Fisher random World Championship
this year he's winning title Tuesday
pretty much twice every single Tuesday
and now he has taken the speed Chess
Championship that is your streamer that
is your SCC winner of 2022
foreign
[Music]